voilà alors chers amis qui est ici et
qui est de paraît-il relié avec avec
nous en visioconférence bonjour et merci
de votre
présence et de l'attention que vous
portez à ce texte important qui va
bientôt venir en discussion devant le
Sénat et pour lequel je souhaiterais
dégager devant vous un certain nombre de
d'éléments importants d'autant que cette
conférence de presse je suis organisée
au lendemain même de la réunion de la
commission de telle sorte que vous
puissiez avoir en tout premier
les éléments qui se dessinent des
travaux que nous avons fait tout d'abord
si vous le voulez bien un petit mot sur
la méthode vous vous souvenez que le
ministre des Armées avait proposé
au Parlement de rejoindre des groupes de
travail de 60 ou 80 personnes dont
ondurait son a assez peu entendu parler
après et donc le Sénat
n'avait pas souhaité adhérer à ces
groupes et une considérons que le
Parlement a suffisamment de ressources
en nous et dans notre assemblée pour
préparer notre travail nous-mêmes donc
nous n'avions pas souhaité rejoindre ces
groupes de travail mal définis où il y
avait des associations de consommateurs
toutes sortes de gens qui nous
paraissent très intéressants mais
le Parlement a des compétences et donc
le Sénat souhaité exercer ses
responsabilités lui seul la Commission
en vérité saisit très en amont de ce
texte qui est très important longtemps
413 milliards c'est quand même assez
rare de voir passer les documents des
des lois de programmation de cette
importance nous nous sommes saisis très
en amont en ayant donc désigner ce que
j'ai fait les rapporteurs budgétaires
qui m'entourent et qui chacun ont
effectué un très long travail très
approfondie d'audition de visite sur
place pour effectivement bien apprécié
la dimension du texte qui nous est
proposé et c'est donc sur cet ensemble
de 8 rapporteurs en fait c'est moi le
rapporteur du texte mais je me suis
appuyé sur le travail des 8 sénateurs de
diverses sensibilités je souhaite
souligner ce point qui sera une trame
permanente dans mon propos puisque vous
verrez que c'est globalement très
consensuel le travail qui a pu être
effectué
et donc assez transpartisans ce qui nous
permet je l'espère d'enrichir très
substantiellement le texte est d'en
corriger un certain nombre de défauts
d'ores et déjà au cours de la matinée
d'hier 171 amendements ont été adoptés
dont 80 amendements que j'ai eu
l'honneur de présenter avec mes
co-oporteurs donc un travail assez
approfondie ça c'est pour la pour la
méthode alors voyons maintenant un petit
peu le fond du texte je vais donner un
certain nombre d'éléments d'appréciation
et je soulignerai après si vous le
voulez bien les les points
d'amélioration que le Sénat souhaite
apporter
sur l'analyse que nous faisons de la loi
de programmation militaire après de ces
nombreuses auditions et avoir entendu à
deux reprises très longuement le
ministre plus des entretiens privés que
moi j'ai eu avec lui donc il se dégage
un premier paradoxe c'est un texte qui a
été fait dans une certaine urgence
puisque on arrête la loi de
programmation militaire actuelle deux
ans plus tôt que prévu alors on s'est
évidemment interrogé sur la la raison à
cette urgence et bien évidemment la
guerre en Ukraine si on relie les propos
du président de la république ayant en
Ukraine qui a considérablement changé la
donne géopolitique et moi-même qui fut
rapporteur de la précédente LPM j'ai pu
constater tout au long de ces années le
changement
[Musique]
très important dans le contexte
géopolitique que connaît le monde depuis
cinq ou six ans
et donc en vérité nous nous attendions à
retrouver ce ce changement ce sens ce
sentiment de changement de l'air
stratégique dans la revue nationale
stratégique la RNS et puis bien
évidemment dans le projet de loi de
programmation militaire et je dois dire
que c'est pas faire un jure
au rédacteur de cette revue que nous
avons été considérables que nous avons
été très sensiblement déçus parce que
bien évidemment une loi de programmation
militaire doit dégager les réponses que
nous devons apporter aux menaces encore
faut-il bien identifier les menaces et
le texte de la RNS qui était celui d'une
trentaine de pages enfin environ
manifestement n'avait pas été aussi loin
qu'avait pu aller et le livre blanc et
la revue National stratégique qui avait
eu lieu précédemment
[Musique]
un chiffre important du crédit nous
n'arrivons que progressivement à
remonter la pente alors
le second paradoxe qui est qu'est-ce
qu'avec et pourquoi est-ce qu'avec 400
milliards d'euros on ne peut pas
financer une relance suffisamment forte
de notre effort de défense
alors à la fois donc je l'ai dit un
effort budgétaire significatif mais le
texte reste délibérément assez flou et
avec un certain nombre de modifications
sur lequel je vais revenir et qui
explique ce flou et donc cela comporte
et cela entraîne si vous le voulez des
révisions à la baisse de certains
objectifs avec des décalages sur le
temps c'est-à-dire des programmes qui en
fait ne viendront à leur haut niveau
qu'après 2030
en vérité la question qu'on s'est posée
c'est pourquoi avec plus d'argent on a
un texte qui revoit des objectifs à la
baisse c'est un petit peu ça le paradoxe
c'est un petit peu ça la difficulté
alors à ça il y a plusieurs raisons que
nous avons identifié comme nos collègues
de l'Assemblée nationale en plus de fer
tout d'abord l'inflation l'inflation que
nous ne connaissions pas les années
précédentes vous l'avez vu c'est une
annonce du ministre lui-même sur 400
milliards c'est un c'est inflation à
vraisemblablement un impact de 30
milliards au minimum peut-être plus
parce qu'on tape sur une inflation de de
3 ou 4% mais on s'aperçoit que pour
l'instant on est sur des pentes et qui
sont qui sont supérieures
non seulement il y a l'inflation qui
explique que ces difficultés mais il y a
un effet qui a été assez peu souligné
jusqu'à présent un effet de génération
des équipements en effet si on regarde
nos années au début de la LPM actuelle
on voit que ces années
fonctionnaient en réalité sur les
derniers acquis de la de la guerre
froide ont fonctionné avec des matériels
qui étaient déjà assez anciens pour ne
pas dire usager pour nombre d'entre eux
je pense au Puma au Zaz aux alouettes 3
au gazelles
au mirage des ravitailleurs aériens
tout ça avait été commandé je rappelle
par le général de Gaulle ce qui est
quand même date des VAB des AMX les
AMX-10 date des années 70 alors tout ça
faisait encore une partie intégrante et
importante des matériels de nos forces
armées donc bien évidemment comme c'est
tous ces équipements sont à bout de
souffle et comme on a
passablement désinvestis dans notre
outil de défense depuis la depuis la fin
de la guerre froide vous vous souvenez
de cette phrase légendaire de rester
historique de Laurent Fabius nous allons
toucher les dividendes de la paix
résident de la paix évidemment
rétrospectivement on se demande où ils
sont et donc maintenant ces équipements
étant à bout de souffle il a fait il
faut investir massivement sur une
nouvelle génération d'équipements et sur
un renouvellement de capacité et bien
sûr la technologie et l'innovation
aidant et les progrès les notamment en
matière de communication aidant
évidemment le coût d'un griffon n'est
pas le coût d'un Vabe et donc il ne
coûte pas du tout le même prix donc pour
le prix d'un vape on aurait pu pour le
prix d'un griffon on aurait acheté
beaucoup de vagues mais il faut bien
évidemment
remonter à la fois en puissance et en
intensité donc la nécessité de de
remettre nos forces armées à niveau
nécessite l'acquisition de beaucoup de
matériel dans toutes les armes et ce
matériel coûte évidemment beaucoup plus
cher
une troisième raison qui est très très
importante et tout à fait fondamentale
et dont on a vu les effets pervers dans
les précédentes années et il faut les
rechercher du côté du programme 178
c'est-à-dire la mise en condition
opérationnelle de nos forces depuis
longtemps en fait s'appuyant sur 70 ou
75 ans de paix
les gouvernements successifs
considéraient que nos forces ne seraient
jamais engagées dans un conflit de haute
intensité on se limitait à organiser nos
forces sous forme de corps
expéditionnaire pour des opérations de
paix en Afrique ou ailleurs sous mandat
de l'ONU mais on n'avait jamais imaginé
que la guerre reviendrait à 3 heures de
Paris et donc c'était assez facile pour
les ministres du Budget qui se sont
succédés de diminuer les crédits ce qui
fait qu'on a systématiquement rogné sur
les stocks sur les munitions sur
l'entraînement sur les soutiens sur la
mise en condition opérationnelle sur
les équipements du génie sur le service
de santé des armées en se disant de
toute façon il y a pas de guerre en
prévision et donc nous n'en aurons pas
véritablement besoin
pour vous donner quelques exemples que
je souhaitais livrer à votre réflexion
on a je prends l'exemple des chars
Leclerc nous n'avons plus que 200 chars
à peu près en état de fonctionner je
rappelle que
la Russie en a déjà perdu en un an de
guerre on a perdu 2000 ça c'est du
conflit de haute intensité et
elle a perdu 2000 charges contre un pays
l'Ukraine qui n'a que 40 millions
d'habitants donc vous voyez que le
conflit de haute intensité faut pas se
payer de mots si nous devions connaître
une telle un tel drame bien évidemment
il exposerait nos forces et nous voyons
bien ce qui a été dit par vous et par de
nombreux observateurs
en qualifiant
nos forces armées de très riches sur le
plan de tous les segments mais quasiment
sans épaisseur puisque nous n'avons pas
la quantité de matériel nécessaire donc
je dis
nous nous prenions un autre exemple à la
fin de à la fin de la LPM actuelle nous
aurions en stock en missile de de en
missiles complexe l'équivalent de ce qui
a été tiré la semaine dernière en
Ukraine donc vous voyez que on n'est pas
du tout exactement dans les mêmes dans
les mêmes profils
de la même manière toujours sur ces
chars Leclerc les personnels qui les
servent s'entraînent à moitié de leur
personnel faute de moyens à moitié de
leur potentiel donc
on a ce qui nous permet de dire en
simplifiant bien évidemment les choses
nous avons quatre régions de Charles
Leclerc avec les moyens pour faire
fonctionner à plein régime de régiment
c'est à dire que finalement sur ces
forces avec tout le dévouement de nos
forces armées et la meilleure volonté du
monde malheureusement donc c'était
érintement des des moyens opérationnels
à lourdement
pénaliserait lourdement l'engagement de
nos troupes si nous entrions dans un
conflit de haute intensité en vérité
vous l'avez compris et vous l'écrivez
vous-même le monde a changé avec la
guerre en Ukraine et donc les règles du
jeu ont évidemment tout aussi changé et
donc en fait ce que nous attendions de
la de la revue stratégique c'était de
répondre à la question fondamental à
laquelle une LPM doit répondre quel
modèle d'armée voulons-nous quel modèle
d'armée voulons-nous c'est à dire après
avoir identifié les menaces comment y
répondre nous comment y répondre nous
sur le plan national mais aussi dans le
cadre de nos alliances autant
coopération sur le plan européen et donc
à partir du moment où on aurait pu
défendre
identifier le modèle d'armée que nous
souhaitions nous en aurions défini plus
facilement les moyens évidemment la
conclusion c'est que s'il s'agit de se
mettre à niveau tout ça coûte très cher
et je pense qu'on aurait pu faire ce
travail
de manière plus simple si on avait eu
encore une fois une bonne identification
des menaces et donc la réponse c'est un
texte assez flou ce n'est pas fatalement
une critique
contre la LPM au sens où une LPM qui va
jusqu'en 2030 au jour d'aujourd'hui
personne n'est capable de dire dans quel
état le monde sera dans deux ans dans
trois ans dans 4 ans est-ce que la
guerre d'Ukraine va s'étaler sur
plusieurs années est-ce qu'au contraire
une solution finir par être trouvé
est-ce qu'au contraire la situation va
brusquement s'aggraver avec des tensions
beaucoup plus fortes auxquelles nous
ferons nous serons obligés de faire face
tout ceci personne ne peut le dire c'est
pour ça que la dimension d'adaptabilité
de la LPM et je vais revenir dans un
instant sur les revoyures sur les
réexamens réguliers de de ce texte est
important mais je pense que une autre
programmation même si elle doit fixer
les grandes masses doit tenir compte
aussi de des évolutions qui pour
l'instant sont assez
difficiles à imaginer
donc voilà le contexte général dans
lequel se sont inscrits nos travaux et
maintenant je voudrais vous donner
quelques éléments sur les propositions
de la Commission telle qu'elle résulte
de la longue réunion que nous avons eu
hier et qui va se poursuivre dans les
jours et les semaines qui viennent
jusqu'à l'examen en hémicycle
en fait pour que les choses soient peu
près à peu près clair 4 axes principaux
d'amendements ont été mis en oeuvre tout
d'abord et à mon sens c'est la marque
particulière du Sénat qui était du reste
attendu par nos collègues de l'Assemblée
nationale qui nous l'avaient suggéré
mais nous l'avions imaginé il y a déjà
un certain temps nous avons souhaité
rectifier la trajectoire budgétaire
tout en restant bien évidemment dans
l'enveloppe des 413 milliards dont vous
vous souvenez que c'est 413 milliards se
vantent-ils en 400 milliards
budgétés si je peux me permettre et 13
milliards
extra hors ressources budgétaires
nous avons considéré que le rythme de
dépenses ne nous paraissait pas
correspondre à la nécessité que nous
avions de remuscler au plus vite nos
forceuses armées de compenser
les les dons que nous avons fait à
l'Ukraine d'armes qui certes était
peut-être vieillissante pour certaines
mais les AMX-10 ils marchaient tous ils
marchent tout à fait bien et si on était
projetés dans un conflit de haute
intensité on serait bien content aussi
de les avoir donc il faut pas perdre de
temps et pas repousser comme la loi le
prévoyait à 2017 date par hasard de
l'élection présidentielle donc il
fallait pas repousser à 2027 sur un
autre quinquennat le soin de d'aller
plus vite et donc nous avons modif la
trajectoire budgétaire en quelque sorte
dans tout en restant dans ces 413
milliards nous avons lissé la
trajectoire alors je vais je vais vous
donner deux exemples ça va être très
simple de résoudre les tableaux nous
abonnements le gouvernement nous
proposait une LPM qui sur les premières
années c'est 25 26 27 prévoyait et oui
et 27 puis c'est ça je dis bien prévoyez
3 milliards hors 3 milliards c'est
actuellement le niveau de dépenses qui
est déjà consentie par l'actuel LPM et
donc la question qu'on posait nombre de
collègues c'est à quoi ça sert de faire
une nouvelle LPM si c'est pour rester
sur le même rythme de dépenses et donc
nous ce que nous proposons dans
l'amendement qui a été voté hier c'est
d'augmenter sensiblement la les
premières années de cette trajectoire en
quelque sorte un nouvel une nouvelle
cadence de consommation des crédits qui
se serait portée de 3 milliards à 3
milliards 6 pendant les premières années
puis 3 et 3005 la dernière année donc 3
2 3 milliards à 3 milliards 5 alors
ce qui fait environ globalement
des crédits supplémentaires tout à fait
substantiel de l'ordre de 500 millions
par année jusqu'à 2027
ceci permet de répondre à une question
fondamentale que nous sommes posées je
vous ai parlé de ces 13 millions 13
milliards non budgétés bien là le fait
de les reventiler tout de suite des
cette année les frères rentrés dans les
crédits budgétaires et leur donnerai
donc une certitude d'être dépensé et
d'être utilisé le plus rapidement c'est
du reste la recommandation je le
rappelle c'est pas tout à fait sans
importance c'est la recommandation du
Haut Conseil des finances publiques qui
s'est prononcé ici puisque son président
le président le premier président de la
Cour des Comptes est venu exposer
cette cette priorité
alors vous me direz mais est-ce que
c'est pas un calcul un peu politicien
qui consiste à dire on veut toujours
plus non et moi j'avais donné comme
instruction à mes rapporteurs de de
fonder ces crédits supplémentaires sur
de véritables besoins c'est-à-dire pas
simplement du toujours plus car on sait
très bien et on a tout à fait conscience
de la situation budgétaire et financière
de la France je l'ai dit à madame la
Première ministre avec qui j'ai eu un
entretien sur ces sujets il y a de cela
quelques jours à peine nous avons fondé
cette augmentation sur un certain nombre
de dépenses que nous souhaitons voir
inscrite immédiatement dès l'entrée en
vigueur de la loi de programmation alors
quelques exemples tout d'abord bien
évidemment mettre de l'argent
supplémentaire sur l'activité des forces
là on avait manifestement jusqu'en 27
une stagnation du taux d'activité des
forces et qui distinguation d'activité
du taux d'activité des forces dit moins
d'entraînement moins d'équipements et
moins de préparation à un éventuel
conflit difficile
donc concrètement on prévoit
pour 2024 c'était des immédiatement 240
millions d'euros supplémentaires pour
l'activité des forces c'est à dire
injecter dans le dans la préparation de
nos forces une somme conséquente
de même ça c'est pour l'activité des
forces toujours dans ces 500 millions de
plus chaque année on veut renforcer le
capacitaire et il nous paraît nécessaire
de corriger certaines réductions qui
apparaissent dans la LPM par exemple
vous aviez vu que le programme scorpion
qui était une priorité de la loi de
programmation militaire précédente avait
été fortement réduit le texte initial
prévoyait un ralentissement de 30% moins
30% du programme scorpion déjà
l'Assemblée nationale a traversé
d'amendements à réduit ce freinage à 21%
pour les seuls griffons et nous nous
proposons de ralentir on accepte l'idée
de le ralentir mais pas plus que 15%
pour les Griffons les jaguars et le
programme Serval donc on veut redonner
un tout petit peu de un tout petit peu
de consistance à ce programme parce que
sans ça on a l'impression de d'assister
à une remise en cause justifier d'un
programme qui paraissait prioritaire
dans la LPM précédente et donc à partir
du moment où la revue nationale
stratégique ne nous indiquait pas des
raisons certaines de revoir ce programme
même si nous comprenons encore une fois
que la mise en condition opérationnelle
doit mobiliser des crédits mais il nous
apparaît qu'il faut faire un effort sur
le programme scorpion sur l'équipement
de nos forces dont nous avons absolument
besoin de la même manière nous
souhaitons muscler la capacité de
l'hélicoptère Tigre vous savez que sur
ce sur ce programme nous avons connu
enfin nous avons enregistré la mauvaise
nouvelle du départ des allemands sur ce
programme et nous voulons néanmoins
sauvegarder ce programme avec dans ces
enveloppes supplémentaires la
possibilité d'y ajouter un missile eau
de tram ce qu'on appelle un MHT un
missilo de tram souverain au lieu du
Hellfire américain qui était
initialement prévu donc là de la même
manière que nous souhaitons accroître la
capacité de combat collaboratifs
notamment avec l'équipement de drone qui
sont un élément tout à fait nouveau par
rapport à la présente LPM une priorité
nouvelle à l'éruption des drones vous
avez vu ce que les drones ont pu
enfin les conséquences que leur
utilisation a eu tente en armée dans le
conflit Arménie Azerbaïdjan que
évidemment en Ukraine donc là il faut
pas perdre de temps et accélérer le
programme drone de la même manière
toujours dans l'utilisation de ces
crédits de 500 millions supplémentaires
dans le recadencement nous souhaitons
revenir à un chiffre de 37 appareils à
400m initialement c'était un minimum de
35 prévus parce que sinon là c'est un
danger industriel il y a un risque
d'arrêt de la production d'un appareil
qui après des des débuts un peu
compliqué à montrer l'excellence de sa
conception et qui maintenant est utilisé
par de très nombreuses armées
occidentales et même ailleurs
de la même manière
en ce qui concerne les patrouilleurs ou
les patrouilleurs hauturiers de la
Marine nationale qui était ramené à 7
nous souhaitons les porter à 10 parce
que les patrouilleurs nous sommes très
importants pour une priorité que nous
approuvons à savoir une meilleure
protection et une meilleure sécurité de
nos territoires d'outre-mer ça c'est un
choix que nous approuvons encore faut-il
lui donner les moyens et les
patrouilleurs hauturiers en sont un
élément donc ça c'est si vous voulez une
première justification c'est la
justification de cette priorité qui
consiste à améliorer la trajectoire
budgétaire de
600 millions
sur les premières années sans attendre
le deuxième axe qui a motivé qui a
mobilisé notre
réflexion et qui a entraîné de nombreux
amendements c'est la volonté d'améliorer
les moyens de contrôle du Parlement sur
l'exécution de la loi de programmation
militaire j'ai dit tout à l'heure que
les sommes étaient très importantes et
parfois assez floues à la limite on peut
le comprendre et l'accepter compte tenu
de la fiabilité du contexte
géostratégique que nous connaissons
encore faut-il que le Parlement puisse
exercer
son contrôle ce qui est sa vocation
constitutionnelle dans l'exécution de la
loi de programmation militaire alors
ainsi nous avons fait voter des
amendements qui visent à préciser les
trajectoires d'entretien des matériels
et les trajectoires d'activités car tout
ça représentait des chiffres globaux
très importants savoir
par exemple sur l'entretien des
matériels selon quel calendrier
tous ces dispositifs sont mis en œuvre
est-ce que nous voulons c'est
transmission des éléments qui nous
permettent de contrôler pour ne pas
arriver à la situation que l'on avait
connue jadis ou 50% des hélicoptères ne
français ne pouvaient pas décoller faute
de personnel de pièces détachées ou
d'entraînement de la même manière nous
avons des amendements qui vise à nous
donner accès à l'a2pm c'est je rappelle
que la 2PM c'est l'ajustement annuel de
la programmation militaire comme son nom
l'indique ajustement annuel de la
programmation militaire si nous n'avons
pas accès à l'ajustement annuel qui nous
semble normal qui est régulier là la vie
militaire et la situation internationale
n'est pas quelque chose de figé mais si
chaque année le ministère a procède par
des tableaux statistiques à un
ajustement annuel de cette programmation
il faut que nous que nous rapporteurs
puissent avoir accès à ce contrôle de la
même manière
nous souhaitons avoir accès à certains
contrôles à certains indicateurs
d'activités et de disponibilité ce qu'on
appelle les fameux DTO qui étaient
accessible jusqu'à présent et qui semble
nous être interdit depuis quelques temps
alors si vous ne pouvez pas contrôler ni
la programmation ni l'indicateur
d'activité et de disponibilité j'allais
dire à quoi sert-on on va pas contrôler
le savoir s'il y a 3 milliards ou 5
milliards qui ont été dépensés il faut
qu'on puisse effectivement rentrer dans
ce détail et le DTO sont véritablement
sont une exigence que nous portons avec
la plus grande fermeté de la même
manière vous verrez des amendements sur
un sujet que vous connaissez nombre
d'entre vous qui est la volonté d'avoir
plus de visibilité sur le contrôle des
exportations d'armement et à ce sujet je
déposerai moi-même un amendement
très important dans en prévision de la
discussion en séance visant à mieux
contrôler par l'intermédiaire de la
délégation parlementaire au
renseignement de mieux contrôler le les
exportations d'armement nous savons très
bien que c'est une un privilège de
l'exécutif nous respectons tout à fait
ce cette disposition quasi
constitutionnelle mais dans tous les
pays
occidentaux les États-Unis j'en parle
même pas la Grande-Bretagne l'Allemagne
etc il y a un contre parlementaire des
exportations d'armement ce qui n'existe
que j'allais dire très modestement dans
notre pays où nous recevons chaque année
à une petit rapport d'une trentaine de
pages qui n'explique pas grand chose
donc nous reviendrons sur ce sujet en
séance publique par un amendement
important que je porterai qui ne
réjouira peut-être pas le gouvernement
qui est assez
qui n'est pas très réceptif sur cette
affaire mais sur lequel je pense que des
efforts seront nécessaires donc
renforcer le cadencement sur les
premières années améliorer les moyens de
contrôle du Parlement le troisième axe
c'est conforter notre BITD c'est-à-dire
nos industries de défense avec une idée
assez décoiffante qui peut paraître
original mais qui nous paraît très
intéressant c'est la création d'un
livret d'épargne souveraineté qui
permettrait de financer labilité des
vous savez que nos industries défendent
sont maintenant confrontés aux règles du
taxonomie et au réticences des milieux
bancaires et de tout un tas
d'organisations qui considèrent que
financer l'effort de défense c'est une
chose éthiquement très très contestable
et donc ce qui fait que nombre de nos
industriels et singulièrement de leur
sous-traitants nous font régulièrement
état de difficultés à financer à
financer leurs investissements leurs
recherches et
la fabrication de leurs produits et donc
ce que nous souhaitons c'est un clin
d'oeil un geste qui consiste à dire mais
pourquoi nos citoyens nos concitoyens ne
seraient pas eux-mêmes intéressés au
renforcement de leur propre sécurité on
fait de grands discours sur le lien
armée nation on lance le essai nu on
lance tout un tas de sujets là-dessus et
finalement permettent à n'importe quel
citoyen à hauteur de bien sûr sur la du
volontariat et à hauteur de ses moyens
d'investir avec des avantages financiers
qui seraient afférents qui permettrait
de financer la BITD c'est un peu
l'esprit du Livret de Développement
Durable vous avez vu que on permet dans
des conditions un peu plus avantageuses
que le livret A de financer toutes les
industries qui s'intéressent à la
protection de notre environnement et
bien là on voudrait donner la
possibilité à nos concitoyens d'investir
pour leur propre profit dans les
industries de défense et finalement on
peut imaginer que avoir
quelques actions de d'assaut ou de
Thalès il y aurait plutôt dans un dans
une bonne direction de la même manière
nous souhaitons toujours pour conforter
l'habiter il y a eu des amendements qui
visent à améliorer l'attractivité des
métiers de des industries de défense
le quatrième axe qui supporte nos nos
amendements c'est le renforcement des
des recrutements des relations humaines
au sein des armées vous avez vu
qu'actuellement les forces armées
quelles qu'elles soient subissent de
plein fouet
non pas une crise mais en tous les cas
un très grand déficit dans les
recrutements ce qui fait que lorsque
vous prévoyez 1500 recrutements la
réalité c'est que vous en avez la moitié
et ce qui évidemment pose des problèmes
parce que si vous n'avez pas
l'évocation pour venir mettre en oeuvre
ses efforts de défense bien évidemment
ça risque de poser à terme des problèmes
et parallèlement nous avons pris un
certain nombre de disposition
d'amélioration sur la réserve
opérationnelle vous savez que la réserve
opérationnelle nous approuvons tout à
fait cette priorité ça consiste
effectivement selon le souhait du
ministre à avoir un réserviste pour deux
hommes d'actifs enfin deux personnels
d'actives alors le principe nous va très
bien la seule chose c'est qu'on veut
savoir dans quelles conditions pourquoi
faire et on voudrait fluidifier et
simplifier ce dispositif et ne pas avoir
un seul statut de la réserve
opérationnelle mais peut pas avoir une
flexibilité qui lui permet de s'adapter
aussi aux employeurs parce qu'il y a
beaucoup d'employeurs qui sont assez
réticents à laisser voir partir leur
personnel dans la réserve opérationnelle
parce que les règles actuellement qui
sont des règles nationales sont très
contraignantes par exemple obtenir la
régionalisation de la réserve de telle
sorte que celui qui a qui habite à
Nantes soit pas obligé d'aller faire sa
période de réserve à Strasbourg ce
serait quand même un peu plus flexible
et un peu plus productif pour recruter
des volontaires pour cette réserve qui
par ailleurs nous sommes un très bon
complément de des recrutements au sein
des forces armées de la même manière
nous avons voté un certain nombre de
dispositions sur les grilles indiciaires
avec
des propositions sur les dates limites
de révision des grilles bon c'est un
tout petit peu technique mais je pense
que ça peut être important pour
renforcer
l'attractivité de nos forces armées et
bien évidemment toujours j'allais dire
d'une manière générale dans le cadre du
redressement de de la trajectoire
budgétaire nous souhaitons que les
moyens financiers consacrés au RH soit
accrue par je prends deux exemples le
service de santé désormais et le
Commissariat aux armées on sait que là
pour le service de santé aux armées on a
un déficit de l'ordre sans même
peut-être plus que 100 médecins ce qui
est évidemment très important pour la
mise en oeuvre de ce service la même
chose pour le Commissariat aux armées
absolument essentiel pour la gestion des
forces armées ben là il faut en tirer
les conséquences moi quand j'étais chef
d'entreprise et que je mettais un poste
à petite entreprise mais quand je voyais
qu'un poste ne trouvait pas preneur
c'est que je me disais que les
conditions de travail qui étaient
réservées à ce poste n'était pas
suffisant et donc quand je vois parfois
au titre 2 c'est-à-dire celui du budget
du personnel il y a des enveloppes assez
conséquentes et que dans le même temps
on n'est pas assez attractif pour
attirer de nouvelles vocations au sein
des forces armées c'est que parfois il
est nécessairement du reste et de revoir
les les
grilles de rémunération parce que vous
comprenez bien que dans ces métiers qui
deviennent de plus en plus pointues et
technologiques
l'attractivité du l'industrie privée
peut faire des dégâts quelqu'un qui
s'occupe de la dissuasion et qui payait
moins de 2000 euros évidemment il risque
d'être très rapidement débauché au
profit d'une pointe qui peut payer
beaucoup plus voilà Mesdames et
Messieurs en tentant en essayant de vous
avoir résumé de manière la plus claire
les apports du Sénat sur cette loi de
programmation voilà globalement le sens
dans lequel souhaite aller le Sénat au
cours de la discussion qui va intervenir
dans la dernière semaine de juin donc un
cadencement nouveau qui intensifie le
niveau des dépenses dès la première
année de la loi de programmation et non
pas après 2027 pour les raisons que j'ai
indiquées les moyens de contrôle à
renforcer la part du Parlement
sauvegarder et aider nos industries de
défense et un effort particulier sur sur
le recrutement parce que nous
manifestons une forte inquiétude sur la
désaffection des des générations
nouvelles vers les métiers des forces
armées dont nous avons par ailleurs
absolument besoin pour notre sécurité et
la sauvegarde de notre souveraineté
maintenant je reste à votre disposition
si vous voulez qu'on éclaire tel ou tel
point oui François
mettez votre
appuyer sur François Vinel de public
sénat.fr vous parliez de la revue
National stratégique capable vraiment
répandu à la question de savoir quel
modèle d'armée voulons-nous et vous
dites qu'il en résulte un texte flou
mais alors vous quel est votre réponse
dans vos personnellement ou la
commission
c'est que dans leur audition du ministre
c'est une question qui a été évoquée sur
un manque de réflexion en amont mais
donc pour vous est-ce qu'il faut
continuer d'être sur un modèle complet
faire un peu de tout un peu de tout mais
peu
ou faire des choix
le texte qui nous est proposé parce que
moi je suis pas le gouvernement donc je
n'ai pas me substituer évidemment aux
orientations du gouvernement mais
justement l'impression que qu'on retire
de ce texte c'est que on navigue entre
les deux je pense que
u égard et là je donne mon sentiment
personnel il y a à notre position qui
n'est pas qui n'est plus celle d'une
très grande puissance
nos moyens financiers nos difficultés
budgétaires je pense que de vouloir se
comparer à des armées telles que celles
des États-Unis
serait une gageure absolument
inatteignable je reconnais du risque par
ailleurs nous restons malgré tout et
malgré les difficultés que j'ai
identifiées nous restons une des
meilleures armées du monde et en tous
les cas la meilleure armée d'Europe par
la mobilité et la capacité de de
projection que nous avons conservé mais
ce sont des schémas qui fonctionnaient
auparavant c'est à dire que maintenant
le but essentiel n'est plus d'aller
même si ça reste une priorité sous
d'autres formes que l'on fera préciser
du reste en discussion l'Afrique va être
de moins en moins prioritaire compte
tenu de la de notre situation et des
difficultés que nous reconnaissons en
Afrique une partie de ces forces
risquent d'être basculer sur l'Europe
centrale je pense à la Roumanie aux
Pays-Bas et que je rencontrais ce matin
ou bien la Pologne mais le problème est
de d'essayer de de
bonifier d'optimiser ce que nous avons
fait
avec les meilleures compétences sans
vouloir encore une fois se mesurer au
plus grandes armées du monde nous avons
des capacités il faut les conserver
mais le texte lui ne répond pas et
singulièrement avec ce décalage dans le
temps qui nous paraissait excessivement
dangereux mais nous militons bien
évidemment pour une armée de terre avec
une artillerie une infanterie tout à
fait vélo c'est et
excessivement capacitaire on l'a vu avec
des nouveaux armements qui font la
réputation de la France je pense au
canon César et à bientôt de la même
manière sur le plan sur le plan aérien
l'impact du Rafale commence maintenant
après de longues années de difficultés
commerciales il a pu montrer sa il a pu
montrer son Excellence alors l'idée
c'est de ne pas avoir on est on ne
souhaite pas avoir 1000 rafales mais ce
que l'on souhaite c'est effectivement
les quantités que l'on peut financer au
moins qu'elle soit opérationnelle et
c'est ça c'est un point j'allais dire
positif de la copie c'est l'effort qui
peut être fait sur la mise en condition
opérationnelle encore une fois accumuler
des matériels c'est bien si c'est pour
pas pouvoir les utiliser c'est
évidemment tout à fait critiquable donc
en fait il faudrait arriver ce que nous
attendions à fixer le la projection
d'une armée qui reste la meilleure armée
européenne nous sommes
membres du Conseil de sécurité nous
avons des responsabilités quasiment sur
tous les continents mais évidemment sans
rechercher systématiquement et partout
la la des capacités que nous ne sommes
pas en mesure d'atteindre par ailleurs
il faut bien évidemment tenir compte
aussi de nos alliances
et nous serons certainement amenés dans
les mois et années qui viennent à faire
préciser par exemple le rôle tout à fait
honorable demeurant que la France a au
sein des forces armées de l'OTAN ou nous
exerçons souvent vous savez moi je
préside cette année enfin je siège à
l'Assemblée parlementaire de l'OTAN et
souvent nos alliés ont toujours un petit
langage dubitatif vis-à-vis de
l'engagement de la France au sein de
l'OTAN tel n'est pas la réalité telle
n'est pas la réalité car nous ne nous
payons pas de mots je rappelle que nous
avons des contingents de réassurance
notamment dans les pays baltes tous les
jours partent encore des rafales qui
vont assurer la sécurité dans le ciel de
Pologne nous avons maintenant des forces
qui sont établies en Roumanie vous le
savez avec des moyens antiériens
près de 1000 hommes que j'ai dû rester
dont j'étais voir sur place dans quelles
conditions il travaillait donc tout ceci
il faut le conserver il faut essayer de
trouver la forme
d'armée qui est à la fois correspondent
à nos capacités budgétaires et qui
malgré tout demeure le meilleur niveau
et de
compétences et ça seul une revue
stratégique un peu plus un peu plus
épaisse nous aurait permis de mieux
cerner cette réalité c'est la difficulté
à laquelle on était confronté
une autre question sur sur le SCAF vous
l'avez pas évoqué il y a un certain
retard le d'après ce que j'ai compris
donc le Rafale va est parti pour durer
encore un certain nombre d'années avec
un standard F5 qui prévoit des drones
comme essentiel faire le Scaff est-ce
que ça vous inquiète sur hauteur
la coopération franco-allemande du
meilleur général nous pose beaucoup de
questions que l'on pose régulièrement au
ministre
bon je pense que nous vivons peut-être
une période intermédiaire après une
période de faux plat où on a où on a eu
quelques difficultés nos industriels ont
eu quelques difficultés vous vous
souvenez que la la commission de la
défense à mon initiative avait même pris
la peine de confronter en commission la
position d'Airbus Allemagne et de et et
de Dassault puisqu'il y avait un long
débat entre ces deux entreprises sur ce
qu'on appelle la boîte noire
c'est-à-dire le savoir-faire
particulièrement technologique du futur
SCAF il semble que ce pilier 1a a été un
B pardon a été réglé que des accords
soient intervenus et que on aborde
maintenant le pilier 2 vous savez qu'il
y a 7 piliers je crois dans un
voilà il y a plusieurs phases dans la
discussion les informations que nous
avons et du plus haut niveau on a encore
reçu le président de le président
d'assaut dans le cadre des auditions que
nous venons d'avoir laissant entendre
que les choses se débloquent doucement
simplement ce qu'il faut c'est que moi
mon point de vue personnel c'est que il
faut rechercher l'accord des industriels
car les déclarations gouvernementales
sont tout à fait souhaitables mais elle
vise toujours à annoncer des accords qui
ne prennent pas toujours forme et donc
l'idée c'est de laisser les industriels
les trois je rappelle que quand même les
Espagnols sont aussi dans le dispositif
trouver les termes de la corps technique
dans le respect du savoir-faire de
chacun et évidemment la France soutient
les entreprises françaises et
singulièrement d'assaut dans ce travail
commun
nous attendons maintenant des éléments
complémentaires sur de la mise au point
du démonstrateur qui devrait intervenir
sous deux ans un peu plus deux ans et
bon bien évidemment à partir du moment
de démonstrateur
se fera ses preuves on sera entré dans
une phase beaucoup plus opérationnelle
ce que je pense c'est que c'est une
coopération qui est absolument
nécessaire
parce que les sommes à engager sur un
appareil de cette complexité fortement
marquée par la connectivité car vous
savez que c'est en fait c'est un
ensemble c'est pas simplement un
matériel c'est pas simplement un avion
c'est les drones les satellites tout ce
qui va avec si je puis me permettre ces
expressions un peu générales donc tout
ceci coûtait énormément d'argent et
alors que nous venons de traverser une
crise de confiance avec l'opinion
publique sur un autre sujet celui des
retraites je sais pas s'il y a des
hommes politiques qui pourraient
prétendre
faire de tel programme tout seul alors
c'est vrai que grâce au savoir-faire
de d'assaut on va vers
[Musique]
une formule
Michelin
un modèle sain
un standard pardon excusez-moi un
standard 5 du Rafale qui va déjà une
amélioration tout à fait conséquente par
rapport au premier rafale que nous
connaissons mais il faut accepter de
faire la jonction vous avez vu que les
Allemands eux-mêmes dans l'intervalle
qui les séparent de la livraison future
de ce modèle ont du procédé à l'achat
d'avion américain donc
il faut encourager cette coopération
elle est très difficile à mettre en
oeuvre elle est peut-être plus complexe
en ce qui concerne la mgcs le char
connecté là les discussions
semblent plutôt patiné ou en tous les
cas ne pas aller aussi bon train qu'avec
qui avait que les initiateurs du SCAF ce
que nous pensons c'est qu'il faut
privilégier et conserver cette
coopération franco-allemande qui est
importante essentielle et qui commence à
avoir dépensé qui commence à avoir
mobilisé pas mal d'argent
mais la mise au point d'un matériel
aussi sophistiqué
nécessite que beaucoup de problèmes
soient levés le problème de l'export le
fait que
le futur Scaff remportera la dissuasion
ce qui n'est pas le cas de l'Allemagne
oui il y a encore beaucoup de chapitres
à régler mais pour l'instant les signaux
qui nous sont envoyés vont plutôt dans
le bon sens ou plutôt dans le bon sens
alors j'ai une question en visio
qui me pose la question
c'est Nicolas
j'ai une question sur les 13 milliards
de recettes extra budgétaires
est-ce que vous êtes partagé les
attitudes de vos collègues de
l'Assemblée sur leur financement et
deuxième question si j'ai bien compris
pour augmenter le cadencement et donc
des différentes marches vous allez
piocher si je puis dire dans ces 13
médias est-ce que vous expliquer
comment ça va fonctionner parce qu'il y
a différentes types de types de recettes
si j'ai bien compris merci
si vous voulez le choix que nous avons
fait et j'allais dire de les 13
milliards en quelque sorte se
décomposent en deux paquets il y a je
vais parler de tête j'ai pas ces 5
milliards 9 qui est 5 milliards 9 et
était effectivement globalement
budgétaire les éléments qui nous ont été
donnés c'est la vente de l'immobilier
les recettes du des du SSA des des
hôpitaux qui facturent bien évidemment
leurs soins la vente de fréquence aussi
qui peut rapporter de l'argent bon on
peut imaginer que 5 milliards 9 sont à
peu près validés sur le plan budgétaire
mais de 5 milliards 9 à
13 milliards il en reste 7 et si vous
voulez c'est là où effectivement à la
fois le Haut Conseil des finances
publiques l'Assemblée nationale et le
Sénat on considérait que c'était des
dépenses qui étaient des des dépenses
qui étaient incertaines au sens où elle
n'était pas justifiée et donc
c'est véritablement alors vous savez
qu'il y a eu un amendement qui a été
voté à l'Assemblée nationale et un
moment tirio je crois c'est un qui a
posé un principe général selon lequel
le gouvernement s'engageait
j'allais dire pour les temps futurs à
budgété les dépenses qui ne trouveraient
pas leur
les recettes à différentes alors nous on
en fait notre amendement et notre
approche vise à prendre le gouvernement
homo et à lui dire bah écoutez puisque
vous vous êtes absolument sûr qu'on
trouvera les recettes pour les 13
milliards le plus simple c'est de les
dépenser le plus vite possible et de les
inscrire dans dans l'ordre budgétaire
que nous évoquons c'est-à-dire de passer
à 3 de 3 milliards ce qui était les les
chiffres prévus par la LPM pour les
premières années à 3 milliards 5 comme
ça on est au moins sûr que cet argent
sera mis sera mis en place par ailleurs
comme je vous l'ai dit le risque de
dérapage de l'inflation est quand même
conséquent de 30 à 60 milliards tout ce
qui est dépensé rapidement ne sera pas
rongé par l'inflation donc
c'était notre réponse qui va faire
l'objet d'apprendre discussion et de
négociation si j'en crois les premières
réaction au gouvernement notre réponse
est justement de dire bah écoutez vous
avez dit 413 monsieur le Président et
ben jouons les 413 et inscrivons le plus
tôt possible c'est dépenses et mais je
rappelle que le Sénat s'en tient à cette
à cette enveloppe et qui ne s'agit pas
pour nous d'en rajouter mais simplement
de les de les budgéter c'est à dire de
les mettre immédiatement dans la colonne
des dépenses qui feront l'objet
du budget chaque année à partir de la
première année de la mise en œuvre de la
loi de programmation militaire
merci je vous en prie
d'autres questions
pour que
vous évoquez d'apprendre discussions
est-ce que ce sera une ligne rouge du
Sénat
que la pratique du Sénat n'est pas de
poser des lignes rouges surtout que les
lignes rouges les lumières générale un
très mauvais souvenir c'est à dire que
cela même qui les ont posé se sont
empressés de les oublier donc ce que
nous souhaitons nous c'est que la raison
l'emporte et que le gouvernement
comprenne la le fondement de cette
approche budgétaire et c'est pour ça que
j'ai souhaité donner des indications sur
l'utilisation de l'argent que que
souhaite demeurant les armées car je
suis persuadé qu'elles sont sensibles
aussi à cet effort que nous souhaitons
mettre en oeuvre le but encore une fois
n'est pas de dire
d'avoir un réflexe quantitatif en disant
3 milliards c'est pas assez il faut plus
il faut plus parce que il y a des
besoins supplémentaires et c'est ça qui
nous qui nous mobilise que ce soit
l'activité des forces que ce soit
l'amélioration du capacitaire j'ai
évoqué quelques exemples on peut pas
rester dans cette situation là alors
même que c'est maintenant que la France
n'est pas en guerre bien sûr mais elle
est dans un état de très grande tension
internationale prenons un exemple aussi
simple que les munitions les quantités
de munitions que nous donnons même si le
chiffre reste discret elles finissent
par nous manquer les amx10 on les a plus
en magasin si j'ose dire et si jamais il
y a un conflit de haute intensité et une
attaque de calculatures que ce soit ben
on les aurait plus puisqu'on les plus
puisqu'on les a fourni à l'Ukraine donc
c'est pas si vous voulez il y a une
inadéquation entre les priorités de de
vigilance du gouvernement et le fait de
renvoyer l'effort à plus tard et de nous
laisser ce qui était le projet initial
de la de de la loi sur un niveau de
dépense qui est celui que l'on connaît
et dans ce cas là ça donne ça donne des
arguments à ceux qui disent mais
pourquoi avez-vous fait une loi de
programmation supplémentaire c'est pour
rester à 3 milliards puisque de toute
façon 3 milliards c'était le chiffre qui
était dépensé actuellement et ça ça
justifie aussi le travail que nous
avions fait précédemment vous vous
souvenez le petit conflit qui nous avait
opposé à la précédente ministre des
Armées lorsque nous avons nous avions
demandé à une actualisation de la loi
comme son article 7 le prévoyait ça nous
avait été refusé c'est bien pour ça que
le deuxième temps de notre réflexion
c'est le contrôle parlementaire pour
voir si effectivement les engagements
les engagements sont bien tenus
alors je crois que vous allez avoir on
va on vous a distribué un dossier qui
est qui est un petit peu plus
un petit peu plus et on l'enverra bien
sûr à nos journalistes qui nous font
l'amitié d'être reliés par visio ah bon
vous avez accès c'est déjà sur internet
donc là vous avez un papier beaucoup
plus fourni sur
à la fois le travail que nous avons
réalisé et que j'ai réalisé avec le
soutien de mes de mes collègues sous
rapporteur si je peux me permettre
d'expression
rapporteur délégué on peut dire comme ça
et je souligne au passage le côté
transcourant que que ces rapports ont
puisque il y a des représentants de
toutes les sensibilités qui m'ont aidé à
préparer ce travail
n'y a-t-il d'autres questions
un mot rapide sur le renseignement je
crois que dans LPM le budget global a eu
l'enseignement augmente j'ai plus
chiffre en tête mais augmente
sensiblement mais vous l'augmenter
encore pourquoi
là ça c'est une priorité que nous
approuvons tout à fait parce que nous
avons pu pointer dans le passé récent un
certain nombre de questionnements sur
sur des problématiques
qui
pouvait mettre en cause effectivement
les capacités de renseignements le
renseignement devient comme le cyber du
reste un élément essentiel de la mise en
condition opérationnelle de nos forces
armées parce que
manifestement
on doit absolument non seulement
moderniser mais pouvoir réorganiser et
surtout amplifier les efforts et qui
sont faits pour saisir
tous les renseignements nécessaires à la
mise en oeuvre de forces armées donc
souvenez-vous quand même des vêtements
récents comme
ocus ou la France n'a pas vu tout à fait
arrivé la remise en propose de cette
alliance privilégiée avec l'Australie
la commission des Affaires étrangères a
pu poser aussi des questions sur ce qui
s'est passé à Bamako et ce qu'on avait
totalement tous les moyens nécessaires
ce n'est pas mettre en cause les agents
qui font un travail extraordinaire mais
peut-être a-t-on mais sûrement à ton
besoin de moyens supplémentaires pour
nous ici au niveau d'une puissance telle
que la France qui doit avoir un appareil
de renseignement parfaitement
opérationnel c'est pour ça que du reste
à titre personnel moi je soutiens tout à
fait le regroupement des services au
fort de Vincennes qui va rendre aussi
beaucoup de fluidité et d'efficacité
dans dans le regroupement de ces
services
et je crois que là
quand on voit les efforts qui sont faits
par toutes les puissances et même des
puissances émergentes on voit des des
services de renseignement de de pays
qui n'étaient pas identifiés comme des
très grands services de renseignements
et bien on s'aperçoit qu'il faut que la
France tienne son on pourrait tenir le
même comportement le même la même
attitude sur le cyber qui devient
maintenant un élément essentiel de la
de la conflictualité et donc là aussi
parallèlement à l'espace et on voit bien
que tous ces sujets font irruption et
que c'est pas simplement encore une fois
de l'infanterie de la marine et de
l'aérien mais c'est aussi tout cette
toute cette enveloppe tous cet ensemble
qui doit être accompagné et là il y a
des efforts substantiels le discours de
Mont-de-Marsan du reste
annoncé le doublement des moyens je
crois que c'était à peu près je crois
que c'était à peu près le pourcentage
qui a été donné par le président et donc
là aussi non seulement au sein de la
commission mais au sein de la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement nous
demandons à la fois plus d'éléments de
contrôle plus de possibilités d'avoir
accès à ces renseignements pour donner
au président de la République à travers
notre rapport annuel les
notre diagnostic sur la manière dont a
posteriori les services ont fonctionné
c'est ce qu'il y a d'autres
évidemment
au-delà des amendements qui ont été
approuvés il y a en commission il y aura
aussi les amendements à la séance bien
sûr qui viendront enrichir le débat pour
l'instant on est encore à une date
lointaine du la date de dépôt qui a lieu
le 27 et donc on aura d'autres
amendements mais je pense que on aura un
débat du même niveau de qualité que
celui de l'Assemblée nationale qui a
qui pouvait laisser craindre quelques
débordements et qui a gardé un très haut
niveau de qualité et je pense que ce
modèle Assemblée nationale nous oblige
aussi parce que
c'est une politique de cet assemblée est
bien connu tout le monde mais
là le vote qui a quand même été massif
en faveur de cette loi de programmation
militaire montre et ça pour moi
l'élément le plus important une
véritable prise de conscience de la
nécessité de relever la garde et de
faire en sorte que nos militaires qui
font un travail extraordinaire avec un
dévouement sans pareil nous les visitons
régulièrement nous les rencontrons je
pense que il était plus que temps de
leur donner les moyens qui encore une
fois ne mettront pas nos forces armées
au niveau optimum de ce qu'elles peuvent
faire mais en tous les cas vont lui
donner des des conditions de travail
nettement supérieur et on peut dire que
en 2030 nos forces armées seront quand
même à un niveau
nettement plus et de plus grandes
efficacité que l'été il y a 10 ans et je
ça a été dit par la commission toute
sensibilité confondues je pense que le
fait d'avoir eu deux LPM successives qui
ont remonté les moyens et qui au final
on multiplié par deux le budget des
forces armées car de 39 on sera passé à
c'est quand même un élément tout à fait
caractéristique au moment où tout le
monde demande tout le monde voit que le
contexte géostratégique se dégrade tout
le monde souhaite que des efforts soient
fait par rapport à cet objectif de 2% du
produit intérieur brut je pense que la
France fait un effort conséquent et bien
identifié et nous aidons à travers ces
différents amendements nous aidons le
gouvernement à préciser ces objets ces
objectifs et à sortir des zones de flou
que j'ai pu évoquer et j'espère que la
discussion sera constructive que la
Commission mix paritaire au sein de
laquelle les les
points respectifs des forces sont
sensiblement modifiées depuis les
dernières élections législatives et
laissent un poids substantiel au Sénat
je pense que tout ça se terminera de
telle sorte que nous n'ayons pas revenu
en deuxième lecture ce qui n'est jamais
bon pour un texte d'une telle importance
s'il n'y a plus de questions je vous
remercie et bien évidemment on reste à
votre disposition moi-même et l'équipe
qui m'entoure pour répondre à l'ensemble
de questions qui vous viendraient pour
préciser tel ou tel point